hello everybody
my name is milana i am a professor at
universidad de sao paulo brazil
and this is my second time here
in warframe conference my first time was
two years ago
and i'd like to share with you my
experience
about simulating electric circuits
and using wolfram matamatchika and
wolfram cloud
the motivation for this work
is uh the need
to provide exercises for students
that are not electrical engineering
students
they are not so motivated
um as i am with this subject
in this year we will not use our lab
because of profit 19 and then
we will have one more one more reason
to think about it here we have a
picture of uh
of some relays that use in our classes
and here we we need we have a exercise
that i needed to simulate to automate
to i'd like
to provide more variations
of secrets and
and i'd like the students to be able to
change their circuits and to use a new
kind of circuit
and to solve a difficult problem
and some years ago more than two years
ago
i did uh first initiative about
this using relay secrets
and then using
mathematical desktop i could
create an interface when student
may build their own secret
and check if the secret works
in this learning interface a student can
build
a comment secret and
using these elements below
for example a relay a timer
their contacts which can maybe
normally open or normally closed
lamps and so on
the elements can be moved using locators
here we can move a wire
or we can
move this relay too it's kind of
difficult
okay here we use an allocator
which appears was modified
so they could look like a usual
electrical representation
can work they work
after all they can check
if the secret behaves as expected
using the operation button
this wire
this wire
okay
okay operation and then we may press
this button
now the circuit only works
if all the connections are done
correctly
the code for this interface for the this
first
interface was kind of long and confusing
and then since then i have learned some
better practice
for example i use
a tube i i still use graph
functions to solve this secret
it's it's very uh the the
my i had to learn
how to draw this circuit
because i needed i
this is a graph with vertices
and edges and the labels
for these edges are customized
by me for example i use a rectangular
a rectangle a red rectangle or a bright
red rectangle to represent a coil
because this is the the graphic
representation
defined in the standard here i use
a button with a open contract
and a button with a closed contract this
is an
off button and this is a on button
but for example i use a locator
here this is a very
useful function uh the problem is
it don't it doesn't work in orphan cloud
okay but in desktop you it works very
well
but my code my code was
for example i used a lists
ordinary lists to show my configuration
all this when i move
or i create or delete some element here
it changes this object here
and here we have the number of the
vertex the vertices
the vertex for example in here is the
position
so i can draw it draw here using
lines where is this vertices i'd like to
put it
here in here the position is
written here and i for example i use
another object another list
to describe the element if it's a coil
if it's a button if it's a timer
and i use only um the position
to show the the kind of parameter for
example here we have the vertex
because it's the it's in the first the
it's the first element of this list
here we have uh this this first element
pair here is the num the vertex
here the six and seven vertex
here we have the six the sixth
and the seventh vertice so i have to
remember
uh the position for each parameter
and then the code is huge because
the data and the the decisions are in
the same place
for example i i did not know how to do
it
using waffle language this is one
problem one big problem
and now as more functionalities are
needed
i decided to do it in a better way
well how to do that
i use it i learned four
great lessons first of all first of all
i need to use associations and rules
because before i use it that kind of
lists
and after that i use that kind of lists
the second one it's the use of
api function in um
together with the cloud functions the
deploy put and gets for example
when i use api function i
i can use arguments that are
mandatory or optional in
any order for example
i may write it into
access then in the cloud i can call it
from other programs and even i can share
it
with another users so if if
you want if if i give uh
uh a specific user or for everybody
in the world access to my api functions
there's no problem the only you
only need to use cloud get
in the correct path for
for my api function in woven cloud
we have here another api function
that are created that
has a lot of arguments some of them
are mandatory for example here
vertices are a mandatory because
i need to to
to know the vertices
uh a description okay it's still
it's also mandatory but
id delay and edge on
they are optional because
here i have the type and then
if the after the type we have the
default value
if there is no id i will put
double quotes instead
so my code will not fail delay if i
don't
uh if i don't uh tell the delay
the delay is zero and then after
the the code
also had deployed it
so if you if you use this
uh the the complete path here i
i need to pass my login name
and then after that you can
access it
uh the third lesson that i learned
was a new set of functions
uh named ask ask function ask display
ask the blade and so on they are very
easy to use
and with them we can build a convex
conversational interface
so a user
should only access the they are the
address for example here if you access
this
address uh
this interface uses this function
and there's a question in portuguese
so you can you must
only you should only uh
browse for a specific file
and submit this file and see what
happened
you don't need to log in in orphan cloud
for example
so it's very useful and people
may use this interface
without knowing it's a know from cloud
interface
though the problem the the last lesson
that i
have learned is
to face the registration about
the use of dynamic functionalities
the dynamic functionalities are not
completely
implemented yet so in this case
i used a simple test file
where the secret is drawn using
characters as dots and
lines i'd like to show you
these two interfaces interfaces
we just need to use this
address here in my
web browser
here we have this
interface so i didn't need
i did not need to
use my warframe login you can
check by yourselves
here we need to browse for the text file
that describes
my secret i will show you how
this secret is is
built we have the draw
that i did using notepad
notepad plus plus for example
here we have a line there's a wire here
and the crossing in the crossings of the
horizontal and vertical lines we have
a terminal we have here
terminal and here and here and here
and the text describes some kind of
elements
here we have the contact a normally open
contact
and its id is d1
here we have a normally closed
button its name is dr
turn off the resistor for example
so if we use this file here
i have this the same
we have this file and then we use submit
okay so this
the secret is wrong here it
is uh created using graph functions
so this dot here here they are vertices
and if i use a graph function here i
could i can i can
see which part of the circuit
is energized for example but
this interface is not finished yet
because i will have to study more
to show how i
can interact with this
edges here i know how to do it using
warfarin desktop
but i need to know how to do it using
wolframcloud
because dynamic functionalities are not
yet
implemented form for cloud
the second one is
another interface and that one
is already it's it's functional
it's not finished yet because i use it a
single
method for secret analysis but
this method is for is
totally implemented so i use it
here
this use this address now it's
it has all the cells equators secret and
s secret solving for example
and then i can use a new secret
or a preset circuit i use a preset one
we have four examples four secrets here
i would choose the
the the secret number four for example
it's more complicated
i use it here i used
ask functions also to
put this combo here this display here
and the submit is automatically created
and i use ask function
so the students can use this interface
to check if their solutions
about these coins about the current from
1 to eight if the soviet steps
are correct we don't need only we don't
need to
only show the value when we
we show the construction
for the linear system so
if i submit here
and then if some
if some student detects some mistakes
they can email me and then
we have the description for each loop
here
we have four loops
so they are described here using the
numbers for the terminals
one three three four four two
one three three four four two
so in this case we have eight
currents so we have eight equations
and after solving that we get the
values so students can check
their solutions
i'd like to thank you for your attention